Welcome to the team,
Mr. Wise.
Thank you.
Now, being an Arizona
Assistant State's Attorney
is an important job,
one we take
very seriously.
In fact, we are willing
to do anything to win.
It's my honor, sir.
And I look forward to serving
the state of Arizona.
Are these marbles?
How's that?
I was just admiring
your container of marbles.
Why, yes.
My wife got them for me
as a gift...
Oh.
For my birthday.
Which brings me
to a speech
I like to give anyone
on their first day
here at
the state's attorney office
of Arizona.
You see...
Lady Justice
is a committed woman.
She's a slippery
little scallop,
as you can observe...
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
She doesn't cook,
doesn't clean,
but what she does do,
is she'll turn a blind eye...
♪ ♪
What is going on?
What?
What are you doing?
Oh, uh...
I don't--
The marbles, they're just--
I got to tell you,
they're just so beautiful.
I was wondering
what it would feel like
to--in my mouth.
Like, what would
the marbles feel like
if they were in my mouth?
[laughs]
That's...you know.
What?
Just, you know...you know.
Like, just what would
it feel like
if there were just kind of
a whole ton of marbles
in my--in my face.
Well, don't do that.
Just...
Just don't do that.
Yeah, yeah, of course,
of course.
What am I doing over here?
I mean, that's a thing
that a child would do, it is.
You were saying?
I was saying
that Lady Justice,
she just stands there
in my office,
looking at me.
♪ ♪
Hey!
Forget the marbles, boy!
Spit the marbles out,
please.
There you go.
[marbles clacking]
Well...
All right.
Ah--
[marble clacks]
How many--really?
Do you have any--
[marble rolling]
[stomps]
I'm gonna wait
for the last--
I'm assuming there's--
Yeah.
I know there's another one
in there.
- Nope.
- All right.
I am so--I'm--they're just
so beautiful.
I can't--
it's just these marbles.
I got to tell you.
You obviously don't
take this job very seriously.
I do, sir.
It's just these
particular marbles.
I just needed to feel
what they felt like
in my mouth.
I don't know what is wrong
with me.
You know we do serious
business here, right?
Yes, I do know that.
I'm 100% aware of that.
'Cause I've forgotten
where I was.
You were saying that Justice
is a dumb, blind, old lady.
I heard every word.
Yes--no!
She's not dumb.
But she is blind.
She's reminiscent
of Kerry Washington
in her prime.
♪ ♪
Good God.
[muffled shouting]
[muffled yelping]
[coughing]
[choking]
[muffled groaning]
[marbles clattering]
[atmospheric choral music]
♪ ♪
[intercom beeps]
Janice, send in
the cleanup crew.
Another one fell
for the marble trick.
[chuckling]
[humming]